l und
[Musik]
prcht schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus wo erreiche ich dich ich
bin gerade wieder zurück in meine Kim
und bist sehr schon wieder im neuen Jahr
oder ich bei mir ging es direkt wieder
so rum so richtig rein immer wenn hast
nichts anderes erwartet oder bei dein
doch meine ich habe immer so diese ganz
naive Hoffnung dass jetzt bald alles
ganz anders wird dass alles gut wird ja
gut weiß und in dieser Welt in der alles
gut wird hast du ganz wenig zu tun ja
weniger zu tun ich aber das das klingt
so klagend weiß ich arbeite ja total
gerne und macht das was ich mache ja
wirklich große Freude und ich frage mich
manchmal das habe ich jetzt dieser Tage
weil die erste Woche war wieder sehr
intensiv wir waren da noch am am am
Samstag in Reutlingen unterwegs war sehr
schön große Halle habe ich Bilder aus
der Arktis gezeigt und es war schön die
Leute da so abzuholen es war toll so im
Kopf gemeinsam zu verreisen und und
schon nach 30 Sekunden waren wir so
gemeinsam unterwegs irwie Richtung
Grönland und hudzen Bay und Alaska und
so und das war irgendwie unheimlich
schön hätte aber beinahe nicht
stattgefunden weil die die Strecke
hamburgreutlingen ungefähr 650 km beim
Versuch sie mit der Deutschen Bahn zu
überwinden hab wir fast gescheitert wir
brauchten zehinhalb Stunden glaube ich
hin und zinhalb Stunden auch wieder
zurück ganzen rutlinger ja mittlerweile
bis zur Arktis gekommen ja h direkt eine
Live Expedition dorthin machen können in
zhbstunden wirklich und dann kommst du
an und du siehst vor dir ich ich war das
erste Mal an diesem Stuttgarter
Hauptbahnhof und du siehst vor dir diese
Riesenbaustelle Stuttgart 21 auch mit
der Bahn zu tun und dann erlebst du
diese diese diesen wirklich geilgen
Humor dieser Bahnmitarbeiter die
wirklich ich kann es jetzt nur
anekdotisch erzählen aber für mich auch
wenn ich ab und zu mal nach Berlin fahre
die sind unfassbar gut drauf und es sind
nette Leute und die strengen sich an und
die retten sich halt mit so einem
geilgen Humor über diese irre Situation
hinweg und erklären den Leuten halt ein
ums andere Mal warum es jetzt gerade
nicht weitergeht und ich verstehe
irgendwie nicht so richtig an er Stelle
das eigentlich passiert ist dass wir so
derart falsch abgebogen sind das ist
erstaunlich also ich gebe dir in vielen
recht also erstmal würde ich sagen es
ist schon richtig die Bahn ist nicht
besser geworden in den letzten Jahren
aber die Bahnmitarbeiter
sindensation viel besser als also in
meiner Kindheit der brummelige Schaffner
in Uniform ja der so aufgetreten ist wie
ein Polizist ja auch Polizisten sind ja
früher anders aufgetreten als heute ja
also so Herr Wachmeister ne also so
Beamter und auch schon mal so schnoddrig
scharfen Jargon und Ton und so und dann
guckt ihr ich meine du musst unglaublich
gute Nerven haben um bei der Bahn zu AR
ja dadurch das alles nicht funktioniert
und H du ist ja ständig mit
unzufriedenen Fahrgästen zu tun und das
einzige was dagegen hilft ist das was
wir unlängst besprochen haben nämlich
Heiterkeit genau und es ist wirklich
erstaunlich wie viel souveräne
Bahnarbeiter es gibt die mit absolute
Mitarbeiter mit absoluter Gelassenheit
und Humor die Dinge kommentieren richtig
ja und auch so ein so guten Umgangston
finden um die Leute aus ihrer
Panikstimmung rauszuholen richtig also
ich muss wirklich sagen es hat sich beim
Personal bei der Bahn alles verbessert
was ich gleichzeitig auf anderen Ebenen
verschlechtert hat ja ist auch
interessant ne W wenn du mit
Bahnexperten sprichst die sagen also bei
der Bahn selbst also auch unter den
Mitarbeitern ist die Stimmung dann doch
vergleichsweise gut das hat auch was
damit zu tun dass man dass man auch Geld
im System hat offensichtlich aber
irgendwie ist es schlecht gemanaged und
das gleiche gilt übrigens auch für die
lufthanser ich ich denke oft wann
begreift ihr mal dass Flugzeuge haben
alle anderen auch ry Air und wie sie
alle heißen aber eure Leute euer
Personal diese sehr sehr gut
ausgebildeten lufthanser Mitarbeiter ja
die es die die es immer gegeben hat und
die es bis heute gibt aber die man immer
seltener trifft wenn man sie aus dem aus
dem Unternehmen ja auch rausdrängt weil
sie teuer sind und so weiter diese sehr
guten lufthansermitarbeiter die sind
diejenigen die den Unterschied machen da
entscheidet sich ob ob so eine Airline
als gut wahrgenommen wird oder nicht
aber irgendwie gibt's dafür zu wenig
Wertschätzung und ich habe ich habe
neulich ein interessanten Gedanken
gelesen in einem wo war das denn ich
glaube in einem Buch von Alexander
solchenizin ausgerechnet und
solchenitin sagt dort sinngemäß
wir müssen mal verstehen als
Gesellschaft dass sozusagen diese diese
die harten Parameter die nackten
Wirtschaftszahlen ja der reine
ökonomische Erfolg ist für eine
Gesellschaft am Ende nicht so wichtig
wie die Frage wie eine Gesellschaft
psychologisch miteinander und
untereinander funktioniert ja es gibt
also es gibt ja keine direkte
Korrelation bei diesen ganzen
merkwürdigen glücksmessungen die man
immer macht der größte unglücksfaktor
ist Ungerechtigkeit Ungleichheit in
einer Gesellschaft also die Menschen
sind eigentlich dort am glücklichsten wo
relativ viele relativ gleiche Chancen
haben und dann ist das egal ob das
Vanuatu in der Südsee ist oder Dänemark
ja also beide schneiden dann relativ gut
ab weil es vergleichsweise
egalitäre und gleichzeitig freie
Gesellschaften sind und dieses
Kunststück hinzukriegen ja also eine
egalitär im Sinne von chanengleichheit
und chanengerechtigkeit auf der einen
Seite und auf der anderen Seite eben
gutes Wohlstandsniveau und hohe Freiheit
das ist so ein Schwager der muss ja
immer wieder neu austariert werden und
da wächst die Anzahl der Menschen die
das Gefühl haben wir kriegen das nicht
mehr hin sind wir eigentlich schon beim
Thema Richard ne ich habe das Gefühl als
auch wir hier in Deutschland wir
verhandeln gerade als Gesellschaft so
ein paar Dinge ganz ganz neu und gefühlt
ist das ganze Land in Aufruhe letzte
Woche waren es die Bauern und jetzt
macht plötzlich ein Wort die Runde das
glaube ich so in der breiten
Öffentlichkeit das erste mal so richtig
besprochen und reflektiert wird nämlich
das Wort Remigration auch das Unwort des
Jahres und der der Hintergrund ist unter
anderem ein Treffen von ein paar
interessante Figuren will ich sie nicht
nennen aber es treffen sich Menschen in
einer Villa in Potzdam und
ironischerweise genau 8 km entfernt von
der Villa in der die die
berühmtberüchtigte Wannseekonferenz
stattgefunden hat äh was denkst du
darüber was weißt du darüber also ich
weiß ja auch nur das was ich jetzt aus
den Medien berichtet wird und die haben
ja erstaunlich genaue Kenntnisse ja also
wir sind ja ziemlich gut informiert was
da genau besprochen wurde wer da
Vorträge gehalten hat wie die Stimmung
war wer mit welchem Auto davor gefahren
ist und so weiter also das glaube ich
relativ gut alles bekannt also es ist
ein Treffen gewesen da waren unter
anderem afdptiker wohl auch Vertreter
der werteunion und da hat ein Mensch
namens selner einen Vortrag gehalten wo
er eben über Remigration gesprochen hat
übrigens ein Begriff der ursprünglich ja
mal unschuldig war also der wurde ja im
wissenschaftlichen Kontext jetzt nicht
in in böser Absicht oder so benutzt ja
das ist wenn einfach jemand der mal
imigriert ist wieder zurückgeht aber
hier war ja was anderes gemeint hier
geht's ja um Umsiedlung wir waren h
wurden Fantasien ausgebreitet bei diesem
Vortrag äh dass man also möglichst viele
Menschen die nicht biodeutsch sind äh
wieder zurück in ihre Heimatländer
bringen sollte im ganz großen Stil
eigentlich ist die Rede von million
dazu gehören auch all die Leute die
irgendwie jetzt ihre arbeitstüchtigkeit
nicht unter Beweis gestellt haben also
alles das wo man sagt den braucht unsere
Gesellschaft nicht die wollen alle raus
Asylbewerber abgelehnte Asylbewerber
Menschen die nicht ausreichend
assimiliert sind das ein ein ein böses
Wort ja also z.B kein keiner geregelten
Arbeit nachgehen oder die die ihren
religiösen Kult
sichtbar vorführen und so weiter dann
kommt man auf eine große Zahl da kommen
auf einige Millionen Menschen und die
Fantasie die ausgebreitet war war also
die müssen wir alle mit
Gesetzesänderungen und ehrlich gesagt
brauchst da für eine Grundgesetzänderung
müsste man dafür sorgen wie man die
Leute alle wieder los wird und in ihre
Heimatländer zurückbringt das war der wo
der Gegenstand und dabei wurde Vokabular
benutzt das zum Teil an nazokabular
zumindestens stark erinnert mm das ist
da abgelaufen ja ich ich ich die
Kollegen von Korrektiv ne haben das
öffentlich gemacht das so e nicht so
eine rechercheedaktion den ein oder
anderen äh kenne ich auch und es sind
sehr gute investigativjournalisten die
da im Werk sind und die haben das mal
genau aufgedröselt ne da waren AFD Leute
dabei unter anderem äh der Mann der als
die die rechte Hand von Alice Weidel
gilt mittlerweile hat rechte Hand im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes so
mittlerweile hat sie ihn entlassen dann
ähm
Burschenschafter Bürgertum Mittelstand
Juristen PolitikerInnen Unternehmer
Ärzte also wirklich einmal querb die
waren alle da dabei zwei CDU Mitglieder
nämlich Mitglieder der wertetig
möglicherweise aufgehend in dem Verein
den Maßen da gegründen will als Partei
ja genau so und interessant ist wer dazu
eingeladen
hatte einer zwei Männer natürlich Frauen
spielen in dieser Welt glaube ich nicht
so eine große Rolle zwei Männer da ein
ist Ende 60 bewegt sich fast sein ganzes
Leben in der rechtsextremeniger Zahnarzt
aus
Düsseldorf gernord mörich und der andere
Hans Christian Limmer ein namhafter
Investor aus dem Gastrobereich ja ähm
und die Aufregung um dieses Treffen ist
jetzt riesig groß und Deutschland hat
eine neue Debatte darüber ob die AFD
verboten werden sollte oder nicht genau
also erstmal würde ich jetzt noch mal zu
dem Inhalt dieses Treffens äh kommen
wollen also diese Fantasien die ich da
gerade äh pauschal referiert habe ne
also die Vorstellung man siedelt
Millionen Menschen schmeißt man quasi
aus Deutschland raus mit Gewalt und
siedelt die irgendwo in ihren
Heimatländern wieder an
wenn man versucht sich äh diese
Gedankenwelt näher vorzustellen dann
weiß ich gar nicht welches von zwei
Gefühlen bei mir das dominante ist das
ein ist das gruselige ja weil wir wegen
des wortgebrauches an Zwangsumsiedlungen
äh und völkervertreibungen und so weiter
denken und natürlich auch ans Dritte
Reich ja Deportation also Remigration
ist das schöne Wort für
Deportation Deportation also Menschen äh
wohin verfrachten gegen ihren Willen im
Zweifelsfall also irgendwo da wo sie die
Hölle erwartet und das andere ist
ähm dieses Gefühl maßlos weltfremder
Albernheit weil natürlich doch jeder
vernünftige Mensch weiß dass das
überhaupt nicht geht also selbst die
Idioten die sich das wünschen und denken
das ist jetzt die Lösung aller Probleme
in
deutschlandm ich meine die Vorstellung
die die Heimatländer werden die Menschen
doch gar nicht aufnehmen das ist doch
absoluter Schwachsinn wie will man die
Leute dahinbringen
100.000 Luft hansaflüge und die Leute in
Länder bringen die sie nicht aufnehmen
wollen also um das zu machen ich meine
es wurde ich habe mir das ja ein
bisschen genauer angeguckt es wurde
erzählt ja ja das geht natürlich nicht
mal ebenso das wissen die Leute auch
dieser selner weiß das auch sonag das
dauert Martin selner ne bekannter
identitärer rechtsextrem sagt das dauert
ein Jahrzehnt oder so was muss in diesem
Jahrzehnt passieren wir müssen das
Grundgesetz ändern ja wir können nicht
Leute weil sie keine Arbeit keine Arbeit
nachgehen einfach in ein anderes Land
umsiedeln vor dem Grund Gesetz sind alle
Menschen gleich wenn wir also sagen da
ist jemand nicht tüchtig ja dann müssen
wir mit dem gleichen Argument auch eine
erhebliche Zahl von hz4 Empfängern
rausschmeißen weil die ja auch dem
tüchtigkeitskriterium nicht reten die
stat deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft und das
Aufenthaltsrecht in Deutschland ist aber
nicht an Tüchtigkeit gebunden das
widerspricht komplett dem Grundgesetz
das heißt also wir müssen also nicht nur
lauter Rechtsvorschriften
polizeivorschriften und so weiter ändern
sondern wir müssen das Grundgesetz
ändern das wäre schon mal das erste und
zwar nicht irgendw im Grundgesetz
sondern wir müssten quasi an die DNA des
Grundgesetzes ran und das ist natürlich
ein absoluter Anschlag auf die
Verfassung also mehr
Verfassungsfeindlichkeit geht gar nicht
also insofern völlig unrealistisch und
logistisch auch völlig unrealistisch
wenn diese Menschen ja oh hin die
irgendwo aufgenommen W abgesehen von den
finsteren Motiven da jetzt eine
Selektion vorzunehmen wer das Recht hat
in Deutschland zu leben und wer nicht
das geht alles sowieso nicht das wird
auch nicht in einem Jahrzehnt gehen das
ist alles Blödsinn und da stellt man
sich die Frage warum diese Menschen die
wahrscheinlich nicht alle dumm sind ja
was für ein gefallen die daran
verschwind haben sich in solchen
Fantasien zu ergehen von denen völlig
klar ist dass sie nicht nur völlig
abwegig sind dass sie grundgesetzwidrig
sind sondern dass sie auch kompllett
unrealistischer kokoloris sind mhm das
ist das was mich ehrlich gesagt
zunächsten mal am meisten beschäftigt
warum gibt es so viele Leute die obwohl
sie eigentlich nicht dumm sind und wie
der Zahnarzt und so weiter sicher auch
mal ein Studium gemacht haben und so
warum die sich da so in so eine scheiße
reinspinnen ich ich glaube ich habe eine
Idee davon dazu gleich mehr ich
würde gerne noch mal Richard etwas
weiter vorne ansetzen ähm die Empörung
ist ja gerade groß dass man sagt also
Remigration und so weiter und dann
gibt's Leute die sagen das hat de eine
völlig neue Qualität ja und dann noch
auch in der Nähe vom vom Wannsee und so
weiter ich fand Harald Welzer ganz
interessant dieser Tage den du nun
bestens kennst der sagt ich finde das
alles ein bisschen aufgedonnert worüber
reden Nazis wohl wenn sie sich treffen
reden wahrscheinlich genau über solche
Dinge ja und sie reden sicher nicht über
moderne Verkehrspolitik also worüber
reden wir hier eigentlich worin besteht
genau die Aufregung und ich ich finde
das Argument insofern interessant als
natürlich auch ein Blick ein in die
Vergangenheit in die Archive sozusagen
da sehr erhellend ist du erinnerst dich
börn höcke hat doch
2018 dieses Buch da was geschrieben nie
zweimal in denselben Fluss genau da
steht sinngemäß dasselbe drin ja pass
auf ich ich ich habe mir das Zitat mal
rausgeholt
schildert dort auch eine Remigration für
die es Zitat eine wohltemparierte
Grausamkeit braucht ja ich weiß dass das
damals medienau dieser Begriff
wohltemperierte Grausamkeit genau genau
und dann dann dann schreibt er von einem
ich zitiere groß angelegten
regmigrationsprojekt kulturfremder
Menschen das kommen muss wenn die AFD in
der Macht ist und das dann
wahrscheinlich auch so sagt damit Opfern
aus den eigenen Reihen verbunden sein
würde und dann der entscheidende Satz
und und da merkst du halt die Sprache
dabei würden schreibt er Zitat ein paar
Volksteile verloren gehen die zu schwach
oder nicht Willen sind sich z
fortschreitend den afrikanisierung
orientalisierung und Islamisierung zu wi
das bedeutet dass also jemand der z.B
als flüchtlingshelfer arbeitet in
knastsoll ja das oder auch abgeschoben
werden genau das meint ganz viele ne das
jas me Bürgermeister der entsprechende
Behausungen für Asylsuchende
bereitstellt Polizisten die die
entsprechenden Behausungen bewachen und
so weiter und so weiter ja mm also meint
ein ziemlich großen Teil der Bevölkerung
exakt also irgendwann sind die Nazis
hier ziemlich alleine 28 ne wir reden
von 28 das heißt wir reden über etwas
das eigentlich bekannt ist entscheiden
neue ist ja nicht dass es Menschen gibt
die sich in solchen Fantasien Suen genau
was ist der also Rechte und recht
rechtsradikale Fantasien gibt es in
diesem Land schon seit Ewigkeiten ja die
hat auch in 50er Jahren und 60er Jahren
und so weiter gegeben und eine kleine
braune Kruste von Nazis hat es in
Deutschland auch immer gegeben leider
leider leider immer alles gegeben aber
was sich verändert hat ist dass wir
heute eine Partei haben die aufgrund der
Prozent sein die sie mittlerweile in
Umfragen
hat 30% in Sachsen über 30% in Thüringen
und in Brandenburg die AFD eine Partei
hat die Tuchfühlung damit aufnimmt wo
man sagt das ist sozusagen Teil des
rechten Randes dieser Partei da gibt
also sozusagen keine klare Brandmauer
die vielleicht rhetorisch oft formuliert
wird aber die existiert in der Realität
nicht dass man also Angst hat dass
dieser Rechte spinnerte Rand auf diese
Art und Weise politisch einflussreich
werden könnte das ist der qualitätster
zu vorher und nicht dass es solche Leute
gibt mm will noch mal sagen und ich
glaube auch das ist wenn du gerade das
ist sehr interessant die Frage ne worin
besteht eigentlich der Unterschied was
ist der Grund warum das jetzt plötzlich
zu dieser Debatte führt das dann auch
dazu führt dass tausende und
zehntausende Menschen jetzt am am
Wochenende auch auf den Straßen waren
was ja sehr interessant ist und auch ein
Zeichen dafür ist wie lebendig
letztenendes auch diese Demokratie ist
wir weisen ja immer wieder auf auf die
Zahlen in Thüringen Sachsen Brandenburg
hin was eher was damit zu tun hat dass
im Herbst dort die Landtagswahlen sind
aber eigentlich Stichwort Europawahl im
Juni wir reden über ein mittlerweile
längst deutschlandweites Phänomen ne wir
reden nicht darüber dass die AFD ein
ostdeutsches Phänomen ist nee nicht ein
ostdeutsches Phänomen allein aber wir
reden darüber dass sie in drei
ostdeutschen Bundesländern mutmaßlich
stärkste Partei werden könnte zum Teil
sogar mit großem Abstand auf die
nachfolgende
parteim und das ist etwas was es in
diesem Prozentzahlen nicht gegeben hat
also hat die NPD in Landesparlamenten
gegeben in 60er Jahren aber es hat noch
nie eine Partei rechts von der Union als
stärkste Partei in einem Bundesland
gegeben das ist eine neue Qualität und
man muss und das macht den anderen
Parteien riesige Sorgen macht Sorge und
wenn man sich mal mit Thüringen
beschäftigt ich glaub wir haben auch
hier schon mal drüber gesprochen ne wenn
du wenn du dir das Thüringer
Wahlrecht und überhaupt das Thüringer
die Thüringer Verfassung anschaust dann
hast du dort äh eine Situation in der es
tatsächlich dazu kommen kann dass ein
Ministerpräsident BN höcke
beispielsweise denkbar ist weilä Dr dr
dritten Wahlgang reicht die einfache
meheit einach Mehrheit ja und das könnte
passieren je nachdem wenn die kleinen
Parteien nicht reinkommen genau und dann
ist eben dann ist eben die Frage was
dann passiert aber noch mal das das
große Ganze richer
ich es gibt Leute die sagen was was was
regt ihr euch jetzt wieder auf was
diskutiert ihr über ein AFD Verbot sogar
dass alles ist Wasser auf den Mühlen
dieser Partei das sagt Sarah Wagenknecht
so das sagt jemand wie Robin Alexander
so das sind Leute die man sag Friedrich
Merz auch und ich bin auf deren Seite
also ich glaube man wird das Gespenst
nicht durch einen
verbotlos ich halte das für totalen
Unsinn weil was passiert denn also a wie
lange dauert es eigentlich eine Partei
zu verbieten ja also wir wissen dass wie
viel jahrelang immer wieder neu darum
gerungen wurde die NPD zu verbieten am
Ende hat man den Ausflucht gefunden und
gesagt die Partei ist so klein und
bedeutungslos jetzt müssen wir uns nicht
weiter darüber rumärgern also verbieten
wir sie nicht ja nicht verboten wegen
Bedeutungslosigkeit mhm es sind ja in
Deutschland schon Parteien verboten
worden es ist ja in 50er Jahren sind
zwei Parteien verboten worden eine
Nazipartei relativ schnell und 5 Jahre
hat es gedauert die KPD zu verbieten die
ist 1956 verboten worden und 1951 hat
man mit dem Verfahren begonnen Wahnsinn
ne ja also damals
Zeit des Kalten Krieges adenauerstaat
Bundesrepublik noch nicht richtig
gefestigt und so weiter die KPD eine
Partei die glaube ich 5,7% gekriegt
hatte bei der Wahl 49 die jetzt keine
große Gefahr für die Bundesrepublik
darstellte die aber die DDR klasse fand
und die Sowjetunion klasse fand und das
alles beim neuentflammenden kalten Krieg
und die wollte dass die Bundesrepublik
deut deschland eher aussieht wie die DDR
und auch von der Wiedervereinigung unter
sozialistischen Vorzeichen geträumt hat
damit also nicht auf dem Boden der
freiheitlich demokratischen Grundordnung
stand und das hat 5 Jahre gedauert und
dann wurde die Partei verboten wenn ich
ein Kommentar hinzufügen m völlig
Blödsinn die Partei zu verbieten weil
das wohlstandswunder hat den Kommunismus
auch so das Handwerk gelegt ist richtig
ja weil bei der nächsten Wahl als sie
noch zugelassen war ja 1953 hat hatte
die KPD noch 2,2% und flog sowieso aus
dem Bundestag das heißt war das
unnötigste von der Welt die Partei zu
verbieten es ging aber darum natürlich
eine Haltung zu zeigen und Leute
loszuwerden und so weil sie natürlich
eine starke Gefolgschaft hatten wenn
auch nur eine kleine aber auch eine
lautstarke und rohe Zahl von
Parteimitgliedern und anderes also hat
man gemacht hat man Erfolg mit gehabt
hätte man aber nicht nötig gehabt mhm es
ist also auch sagen wir mal kein ganz
unverbreiteter Reflex von Parteien
Parteien die man als Konkurrenz
empfindet dadurch loswerden zu wollen
dass man sie verbietet aber was
passieren würde eine Partei zu verbieten
die im im Osten in Umfragen und
demnächst bei Wahlen wahrscheinlich über
30% kriegt dann würden die Leute sagen
wo ist eigentlich der Unterschied also
die Leute die AFD Leute ja wo ist
eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen
Putins Russland und der Bundesrepublik
ja Wahlen bei denen echte Opposition
nicht zugelassen wird und damit könnten
die hätten die einen merthürer Image ja
und könnten sagen das ist der letzte
Beweis der noch gefehlt hat dafür ja wie
undemokratisch die Bundesrepublik ist
und wie wie wie unliberal sie geworden
ist und so weiter wir würden sie ganz
groß und stark machen mhm und warum mhm
ja ja ich ich ich kann das Argument sehr
sehr gut verstehen vor allen Dingen wie
gehst Du um mit einer Partei die
mittlerweile eine Größe erreicht das ist
ja ganz interessant ne die NPD glaube
ich beim zweiten Mal 217 ist das Verbot
ja deswegen gescheitert weil das Gericht
gesagt hat die sind zu
unbedeutend in dem Fall muss man sagen
die AFD Bedeut genau also wenn wenn wenn
du so wenn jeder fünfte sagt ne das ist
aber genau das Angebot das für mich
interessant ist in einem Land ob man das
gut findet oder nicht sagt das ganz
wertfrei ja in Sachsen jeder dritte z.B
ja dann kannst du das das ist die Frage
kann man dann hingehen und sagen das
verbieten wir jetzt einfach ist ja ganz
interessant der Mechanismus auch ne es
gibt ja gute Gründe warum z.B die eine
eine deutsche Regierung ein deutscher
Kanzler könnte das gar nicht der könnte
nicht eine AFD verbieten muss so
Verfassungsgericht MS das machenau
unabhängige Leute können das ein
Verfassungsgericht unabhängige Richter
können das und und das ist auch gut so
ne weil sonst kannst du dir einfach
sozusagen missliebige Konkurrenten
kannst du einfach jederzeit vom vom vomf
gibt ja Gewalten Teilungen klar genau es
natürlich aber es dauert lange ja weil
unhängige Richter müssen das ganz ganz
lange prüfen und du brauchst sehr
schwerwiegende Argumente und die Frage
ist und das ist ja die schwierige Frage
du hast eine Partei die auch von Nazis
gewählt wird und die auch Nazis unter
ihren Mitgliedern hat ja daran besteht
kein Zweifel das aber macht aus einer
Partei keine
Nazipartei diese Partei hat ja
gleichzeitig ein Programm jetzt haben
wir hier mal zusammen durchgesprochen in
dem nun wirklich kein einziger
nationalsozialistischer Wortgebrauch
drin ist oder entsprechende Parolen drin
sindm jetzt musst du ja eigentlich der
Partei nachweisen dass sie
verfassungsfeindlich ist und da reicht
wahrscheinlich der Nachweis dass es
einige Parteimitglieder gibt die das
sind wohl nicht aus mhm und das wird die
ganze Sache natürlich ganz ganz lang und
aufreibend machen und dann werden sich
ganz viele AFD Wähler die keine Nazis
sind und die gibt's ja auch alle ja also
völlig zu Unrecht defformiert sind jetzt
mal Gegenargument Richard es gibt Leute
die sagen na ja also was da neu ist und
darüber haben wir auch gesprochen zu
sagen diese oder lass sie mich noch mal
anders sagen Jacques Schuster kennst du
chefkommentator bei den Kollegen der
Welt der
sich immer zu lesen lohnt und der dieser
Tage etwas geschrieben hat ein
Leitartikel unter dem Titel die
Deutschen sind sich selbst nicht ganz
geheuer
äh und wo dann sagt also da wächst diese
AFD in diese Höhen da gibt's dann diese
hysterische Debatte darüber ja
man beschwört so faschistische
Gespenster und so weiter und er sagt das
greift aber zu kurz weil in deutschen
etwas ganz Entscheidendes fehlt und dann
weiß noch mal auf etwas hin was ich sehr
sehr interessant finde er sagt nach 45
ja äh ist es weder der alten
führungsgarde des Nationalsozialismus in
der Bundesrepublik gelungen wieder an
die Macht zu kommen noch ist es
irgendwelchen Neonazis gelungen quasi
eine eine
gegenelite aufzubauen und der und der
nennt mal die Zahl und sagt das war
keine Kleinigkeit das muss man sich
immer mal vor Augen führen ja für ein
Land das unmittelbar nach Kriegsende mal
vorstellen hatte Deutschland seinhalb
Millionen NSDAP Mitglieder und 4
Millionen Mitglieder da sind wir schon
bei über Zeh weiterer angegliederter
Organisationen die sozusagen im im
Umfeld dieser Partei im Umfeld der NSDAP
zu Hause waren dazu 10 Millionen über 10
Millionen Vertriebene aus den
Ostgebieten die man heute würde man
sagen Ja zu integrieren hatte das ist
eine phänomenale Leistung dass das Land
das hingekriegt hat und ist doch
eigentlich auch der Beleg dafür und
daran musste ich am Wochenende auch
denken als ich diese Bilder von diesen
Demonstration gesehen habe da hat
offensichtlich ein Land seine Lektion
gelernt die Mehrheit der Bürger hat die
Lektion gelernt und sie haben aber mit
einer bestimmten Unterstützung gelernt
nämlich mit der Unterstützung des
Wirtschaftswunders das ist richtig ich
würde das nie trennen die Deutschen
wurden gute Demokraten und
äh und ein kam von einer totalitären zu
einer liberalen Grundüberzeugung als sie
feststellen mussten wie wahnsinnig
erfolgreich dieses System ist und das
spielt schon eine ganz große Rolle man
stelle sich mal vor ist jetzt historisch
natürlich ein bisschen AR konstruiert es
hätte dieses Wirtschaftswunder was
natürlich jetzt kein Wunder war ne
sondern eben auch Entwicklung marshallpl
Unterstützung Westintegration und was
alles dazu gehörte Wiederaufbau das
alles hätte nicht so hingehauen mhm dann
wäre mit Sicherheit der
Nationalsozialismus viel viel
hartnäckiger gewesen aber die Tatsache
dass es fast allen ja nahe zu allen 10
Jahre nach Kriegsende besser ging als es
ihnen in den besten Zeiten vorher
gegangen war ich meine das ist eine
überwältigende Geschichte die aus ganz
vielen Leuten zumindestens auf Zeit gute
Demokraten gemacht hat ich glaube das
spielt schon eine ganz große Rolle und
der Unterschied ist dass die Leute das
Gefühl haben die Rally ist vorbei mm
total guter Punkt die gefährliche
Situation in der wir sind was wäre denn
wenn in Deutschland wir dauerhaft kein
entsprechendes Wirtschaftswachstum was
wir brauchen um unsere Sozialsysteme
Rentensysteme und so weiter zu bezahlen
wir haben und die Angst vieler Leute die
ist ziemlich groß ich meine die
Wirtschaftsdaten für 2024 sehen nicht
gut aus Prognosen sind nicht gut 25 wird
dann auch nicht gleich die ganz große
Wende kommen ja und 25 ist WL ja es es
gibt in dem Zusammenhang nur einen
kleiner Einwurf etwas was mir in den
letzten Wochen zunehmend auffällt weißt
du wenn man so so eine Sendung relativ
lange macht dann dann weiß man welcher
Wirtschaftsvertreter da gerade vor einem
sitzt welcher Ökonom welche Position
bezieht und gibt es Leute topökonomen
die sind eher sozusagen auf Seiten der
SPD zu Hause dann gibt's andere die
sehen die Dinge eher so wie Friedrich
märz und andere sehen sie eher so wie
die FDP das heißt ganz unterschiedliche
weltanschauliche Dinge die da
aufeinander kommen und je nach dem woher
du kommst aus welcher Ecke war das Land
immer entweder kurz vom Untergang oder
alles wunderbar und alles knorke was mir
in den letzten Wochen und auch Monaten
auffällt und das nahmen so mit mit ner
wir kamen ans Jahresende nahmen das
immer weiter zu es gibt mittlerweile
keinen mehr egal welche weltanschauliche
Ausrichtung ja von den Topleuten von den
Ökonomen die sagen es läuft gut sondern
alle sagen es läuft katastrophal und es
läuft auch nicht so schnell katastrophal
s es geht so langsam aber ganz sicher es
geht so schleichend nach unten die
Industriearbeitsplätze gehen verloren
und so weiter und all diese Dinge
Deutschland kriegt den großen schweren
Tanker nicht gewendet so ja und das ist
eben für kleine Länder leichter und das
ist für Länder du hast das ja selber
hier im Podcast schon zwei dreimal
gesagt wir waren wahnsinnig erfolgreich
und wer soangee so erfolgreich ist der
ändert nicht schnell genug genau ist
ändern für uns schwierig ja für eine
Nation die durch die Fertigung ja durch
die Industrieproduktion das ist das
Rückgrad unseres Wohlstandes reich
geworden ist und jetzt im 21 Jahrhundert
sich transformieren muss und zwar
wahnsinnig schnell sich transformieren
muss diesen schweren Tanker mit all dem
was da dran hängt ja lobbyes Verbände
Gewerkschaften und so den kriegst du
nicht schnell genug gewendet und das ist
die Situation in der wir sind und jetzt
entzündet sich der Verdruss immer an den
gerade Regierenden ja als wenn die Ampel
da für jetzt verantwortlich wäre dass
diese Wende nicht gelingt das wäre unter
in in jeder anderen erdenklichen
Koalition und wer weiß vielleicht hab
beim nächsten Mal eine vier Parteien
Koalition dass sie sagt das Regieren ja
sowieso noch noch viel schwieriger macht
ja wir haben immer mehr Parteien es W
immer größere
Koalitionen jeder muss wieder auf den
anderen Rücksicht nehmen und so weiter
und das ist egal welche politischen
Ausrichtungen das am Ende sind ja man
kriegt das nicht gewendet und dann
denken die Leute es liegt an den
etablierten Parteien jetzt liegt aber
nicht an den Parteien sondern es liegt
noch an einem anderen Mechanismus und
das ist der Mechanismus wer sich die
geringste Angriffsfläche gibt mm also
der der mit den wenigsten Ideen in die
Politik gibt der hat die größten Erfolge
Kanzler zu werden das ist leider so und
diejenigen die sagen jetzt bauen wir mal
alles ganz anders um und machen es mal
ganz grundlegend anders und so weiter
die kommen schon in ihren Parteien gar
nicht richtig hoch die lernen in einer
Mediendemokratie dass das das Wandeln
auf ausgetretenen Faden immer das
erfolgreichste Rezept ist und so sind
die allermeisten Politiker die wir haben
auch sozialisiert das heißt eine gewisse
Risikoscheu gehört untrennbar mit der
Erfolgsaussicht zusammen das kommt
erschweren zu einer Situation wo du
einen Tanker vorfindest den du sowieso
nicht mehr richtig gewendet Christ und
da denken die Leute ja das liegt an der
Person und das liegt an der Partei und
das sind die Grünen mit ihrem
Umweltschutz und so weiter ja man sucht
sich dann Feindbilder raus aber das
Problem warum dieses Land jetzt keine
besonders guten wirtschaftlichen
Aussichten für die nächsten Jahre hat
hat damit eigentlich am wenigsten zu tun
das hat mit ganz tiefen strukturellen
Dingen zu tun und mit einer
Mediendemokratie in der die
Handlungsspielräume aufgrund der
öffentlichen Aufregung ja und dieser
ständigen Entrüstung über alles minimal
geworden sind das ist ein total
interessanter Punkt an dem wir gerade
sind Richard finde ich weil ich das auch
hier so wahrnehme sozusagen die die die
ewige Warnung ja vor dem rechten
Gespenst dass da in in in den Pots dann
plötzlich seine seine hässliche Fratze
irgendwie gezeigt hat die die bringt
zwar Leute auf die Straße aber in der
Tiefe in der Tiefe sagen die Leute ach
komm ne geh mir weg ich kenne das alles
weil ich habe gerade ganz andere Sorgen
und das interessante so wie du vorhin
beschrieben hast das wirtschaftliche
Erfolg ja und die Tatsache dass man
gemäßigt bleibt politisch dass man in
der Mitte zu Hause ist und sich auch zu
Hause fühlt dass das ganz ganz eng
zusammenhängt ich würde an dem Punkt
auch die Gegenthese Wagen der Erfolg der
AFD wie viel hat der Erfolg mit der AFD
zu tun mm ist es nicht eher der
Misserfolg der anderen der diese AFD so
erfolgreich se ich auch so ja also die
die die diese diese era Merkel wo Union
und SPD mehr und mehr nach links rücken
und ganz offenkundige Probleme wie z.B
die migrationskrise viel zu lange
verdrängt haben also ist sozusagen das
eigene Versagen mit dem du plöz
konfrontiert bist und und im Grunde
lacht dich dein eigenes wobei es ist ein
hämisches Lachen dein eigenes Versagen
an und und und wir machen dann wieder
auch medial ehrlich gesagt
Symptombeschreibung ja wir die Aufregung
das man muss das auch klar benennen ist
ja gar keine Frage aber der größere
Kontext das ist mein Gefühl ist dann
schon auch noch mal ein
anderer ja also ich sehe das ziemlich
ähnlich und ich ich glaube einfach dass
die also die strukturellen Probleme
nicht die Person Personalprobleme oder
so ja da ist es am Ende egal wie welcher
Minister heißt oder welcher parteie
angehört sondern die strukturellen
Probleme wie wir das hocherfolgreiche
Industrieland Deutschland im 21
Jahrhundert sehr erfolgreich auf Kurs
halten mit all dem was zu diesem
Industrieland eben dazu gehört hat und
das sind natürlich irrsinnig hohe
Sozialausgaben die uns zum Wachstum
verdonnern ja und und Sozialausgaben die
man auch nicht mal eben rückgängig
machen kann ohne noch mehr
Unzufriedenheit zu schüren und so weiter
dann die Bürokratie über die wir
gesprochen haben das ganze ne dieser
dieser ganze
komplexm der führt dazu dass Leute die
sagen wir machen jetzt alles anders wir
greifen jetzt mal richtig durch ja wir
misten den Augiasstall aus dass die viel
mehr Gehör finden das sind Leute die
haben in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik meistens sehr wenig Gehör
gefunden das war so Stammtisch denken
und stamtisch reden aber das wird jetzt
politisch salonfähig weil es gibt so die
die Sehnsucht danach dass man richtig
durchgreift und richtig Z in die Bude
bringt ne und diese Sprache beherrschen
die Rechten seit jeher immer sehr viel
besser als die Linken mhm ne weil die
die Linken zerreden sich und zerstreiten
sich ja und die Rechten das ist auch
auffällig ne die AFD hält diesen
heterogenen Laden der aus Leuten besteht
die eigentlich aus völlig
unterschiedlichen Motiven diese Partei
wählen und die sich nur einig sind in
der Ablehnung der anderen Parteien ja
erstaunlich gut zusammen und das ist
wahrscheinlich auch der Grund warum man
zwar hier den den die rechte Hand
entlässt ja aber sich nicht zu laut und
nicht zu deutlich und nicht zu oft vom
rechten Rand entfernt warum sollte eine
Partei die jeden Monat so etwa 1% in den
Umfragen zulegt ja so einen Fehler
machen sich jetzt innerhalb der eigenen
Reihen über irgendwelche Fragen zu
zerstreiten oder Leute auszugrenzen das
ist der Grund warum die das nicht tun
und mir stellt sich immer die Frage und
das ist die Frage die ich ja nicht
beantworten kann wenn die mal irgendwo
tatsächlich an die Macht kommen sollten
ja wird das dann so sein dass wir die im
Hinblick auf ihre rechtsradikalen
Fantasien immer alle unterschätzt haben
also wenn die viel rechter sein ja als
ich mir das vorstellen kann oder werden
die sich so wie Marine lepen in
Frankreich ja vom rechten Rand ausgehend
immer mehr auf die Mitte bewegen und ich
glaube ganz ehrlich das weiß die Partei
nicht mal selber ich glaube schon
Richard und ich ehrlich gesagt mir wird
dabei unwohl weil ich ich will es nicht
rausfinden müssen ich ich ich finde wir
alle sollten das nicht unbedingt
herausfinden wollen weil ich schon das
Gefühl habe das kann wenn es wenn es gut
läuft in einem in einem großen Fiasko
enden es gibt eine ganz interessante wie
soll man sagen
eine das hat ja alles eine eine globale
Bewegung ja liegt im ganzen ja zugrunde
und da gibt's schon ernstzunehmende
Leute die sagen na ja also jetzt kann
man sagen da haben sich so ein paar
Leute mit komischen Ansichten irgendwo
in potst getroffen ja und der Referent
von Frau weitel war auch beteiligt und
ja sie hat den aber auch rausgeschmissen
gibt aber auch andere Leute die sagen na
ja dieselbe Frau Weidel hat sich mit
einem berühmten deutschen
molkereienhaber in kann zum Abendessen
verabredet der hinterher keinsterweise
irgendwo an ein rechtsradikales
Gedankengut erkennen konnte man könnte
auch sagen es gibt Schlösser in
Mecklenburg Vorpommern seit Jahren wo
sich äh Leute wie Alexander gauland und
andere äh auch mit mit genau solchen
Figuren getroffen haben das heißt es
gibt da so eine Allianz aus eigentlich
äh
ja klar benennbaren Faschisten mit
Vertretern dieser bundesafd und dem
gehobenen Bürgertum also Leuten mit Geld
Leuten mit großem Einfluss ja und und
offensichttig glauben die ein paar Dinge
gemeinsam z.B
äh und und ich glaube da das da wäre man
überrascht wenn man sich das mal
anschaut ich weiß noch 2016 dass wir in
Amerika das erste Mal auf der Spur schon
waren von von von von Trump da kam das
ganz oft die die große replacement
Theorie ja die Theorie und das kannst du
auch in Frankreich hören das hörst du
mittlerweile auch in Deutschland das
sind immer die gleichen Codes es geht um
den Tag X auf dem man vorbereitet sein
muss ja da gibt es diese böse Regierung
da oben die versucht die eigene
Bevölkerung gegen eine andere
auszutauschen und so weiter das heißt da
gibt es schon Dinge wo du merkst okay
das ist jetzt nicht einfach
nur ein
regionales Thema in dem Fall sondern das
ist eine weltweite
Ideologie welweit es ist eine Ideologie
in den liberalen Demokratien so
gegenideologie innerhalb der liberalen
Demokratien so aber mein Punkt ist
Richard die erste Präsidentschaft von
Trump war komplett chaotisch und ich
glaube der Mann der am meisten von der
von Donald Trump überrascht war war
Donald Trump genauso sah das auch aus
die konnten das irgendwie gar nicht
fassen und die hatten ja auch Millionen
Stimmen weniger als als als die
Gegenkandidatin und trotzdem hat
sozusagen durch dieses wahlmännersystem
in den USA am Ende gereicht so wenn du
dir das jetzt mal anschaust die Leute
von Trump nicht mal er selber er selber
möglicherweise auch würd auch mal gerne
an dem Punkt die Frage stellen wie
zurechnungsfähig ist eigentlich dieser
Mann noch der sich so gerne über die
vermeintliche unzurech
rechnungsfähigkeit seines nur 3 Jahre
älteren Konkurrenten lustig macht ja
muss man auch mal fragen an dem Punkt
wie fit ist den der eigentlich und es
gibt auch in den USA mittlerweile viele
Leute die weder den einen noch den
anderen wählen wollen ich würde riesiges
Problem genau weil dieses weil dieses
politische Angebot einfach kein gutes
Angebot ist an dem Punkt aber wenn Du
Dir mal anschaust wie die sich
aufgestellt haben wenn Du Dir mal
anschaust es gibt einen großen Think
Tank auch mittlerweile der der
unmittelbar beeinflusst ist von Trump es
gibt die Zahlen ist man sagt pass auf
wenn wir jetzt noch mal drank kommmen
dann tauschen wir erstmal 50.000
wichtige Beamte erstmal aus genau frein
nach dem krassf Zitat ne die Grenze
zwischen Demokratie und Autokratie ist
die am schlechtesten bewachte Grenze der
Welt ja ist ein super Satz mal wieder ja
also es geht um das schrittweise
Aushebeln des Systems und ich glaube
auch tatsächlich also das würde ich
sofort auch sehen also wenn die AFD die
Macht dazu hätte ja das Interesse daran
das so zu machen wäre wahrscheinlich
groß übrigens auch nur dann hätte sie
diese Durchschlagskraft äh die sie ihren
Wählern ja die ganze Zeit vorgaukelt
dass sie die haben will also du müsstest
ja unheimlich viele Stellschrauben des
Systems verändern ja um überhaupt groß
was verändern zu können und das Problem
ist eben dass die Befürchtung besteht
dass die AFD dann ganz viele Dinge
erstmal inpolitisch ja und dann ganz
grundsätzlich zum Schlechteren äh
verändern wird und dass wir uns dann die
Frage stellen müssen erkennen wir uns
einige Jahre später noch in der
liberalen Demokratie wieder oder haben
wir die Verhältnisse die die peace
Partei in Polen hergestellt hat mit den
Folgen die wir jetzt gerade sehen z
genau ja richtig und es ist ja es ja
total interessant ne wie wie
Informationen ich ich finde in dem Fall
tatsächlich ganz entscheidende
Informationen die kommen gar nicht mehr
durch niemand hat Jemal laut die Frage
diskutiert ja wie hält eigentlich z.B
die AFD mit den Bauern mit den
Landwirten um mit den Subventionen in
deren Programm steht wir wollen das
eigentlich so gut wie alles abschaffen
wollen wir alles nichtm aber
gleichzeitig die Bauern sind sehr
wichtig für die AFD so aber diese
Widersprüchlichkeit ist offensichtlich
und das ist das was mir sorgen macht
diese ganz offensichtliche
Widersprüchlichkeit ist irgendwie kein
Problem mehr und ich muss immer an
Alexander gauland denken der vor Jahren
mal gesagt hat nee nee wenn wir da eine
neue Bewegung gründen und so weiter dann
müssen wir ein Programm haben ja
rontiment ist kein Programm doch
mittlerweile ist rontiment ein
mlerweile reicht aus Prinzip dagegen zu
sein wogegen auch immer du bist einfach
dagegen und die Widersprüchlichkeit dass
du sozusagen dann offen offiziell dich
auf die Seite der Bauern stellst und
sogar versuchst ja diese diese diese
diese Proteste die mit der AFD nichts zu
tun haben aber du versuchst sie
irgendwie zu Kern ja und wirst nicht
gestellt dabei obwohl in deinem eigenen
Programm drin steht dass du noch viel
radikaler an all diese Subventionen
rangehen würdest dass diese Information
sozusagen gar nicht mehr durchdringt das
ist wirklich hart und ich denke manchmal
hat das was auch mit der na Verlogenheit
will ich nicht nennen ich will nicht so
hart sein ich finde auch wir wir müssen
irgendwie mit der Sprache aufpassen das
ist der Job für die nächsten Jahre aber
aber ich sag mal die wollen wir sagen
die die Scheinheiligkeit die da drin
steckt ich meine es gibt dieses 60
Milliarden
subventionsstreichungs Programm Idee im
Bundesumweltministerium
das schon lange lange besprochen ist und
dem alle zugestimmt haben auch der
Streichung dieser quasi klimaschädlichen
Subvention für landwirtschaftliche
Geräte und Agrardiesel und so weiter und
dem haben alle zugestimmt auch die CDU
war damit einverstanden alle waren damit
einverstanden es haben die Kollegen von
von Bild am Sonntag war es glaube ich
jetzt noch mal finde ich toll dass die
das gemacht haben noch mal aufgearbeitet
und gesagt Freunde alle aber das ist ja
Scheinheiligkeit von jedem ne der der
gesagt hat okay da müssen wir irgendwie
ran ja aber die Leute
verstehen die Leute verstehen das die
Leute kriegen das mit und sagen das ist
der Grund warum wir euch nicht mehr
glauben und ich habe heute ein ist ja
gerade Davos
Weltwirtschaftsforum n Ferguson gelesen
den den über den wir hier schon häufiger
gesprochen
haben eigentlich einer der wie soll man
sagen berühmtesten weltenerklärer im
Moment der auch immer gut ist für eine
für eine steile These und der sagt
irgendwie die etablierten Parteien die
haben sich auf eine Art und Weise so
sagen
entfremdet die politischen Eliten von
dem was man das Volk nennt
das das auf keinen Fall mehr in
irgendeiner Form zusammenzubringen ist
und zwar an zwei ganz entscheidenden
Punkten nämlich sag die Eliten haben
sich in den vergangenen Jahren vor allem
mit zwei Projekten befasst Umwelt und
Klimaschutz und mit einer möglichst
humanitären Antwort auf diverse
Fluchtbewegungen und er sagt bei beiden
Themen haben sie sich maximal von den
Wählern entfernt weil theoretisch wollen
natürlich auch die Wähler auch die
Bauern übrigens wollen die Umwelt retten
aber sie wollen dafür nicht auf Ihre
Heizung verzichten und auf Ihren BMW
auch nicht ja und auch die Aufnahme von
Flüchtlingen finden Sie nur so lange gut
wie die ihn keine Jobs wegnehmen und wie
sie keine Straftaten begehen ja aber was
ist die Alternative dazu ich meine die
wir haben ja uns ja schon mal über den
Begriff Ungleichzeitigkeit unterhalten
ne also den Begriff von Ernst Bloch dass
also Problemsituationen und die Weltlage
sich sehr schnell verändern können aber
dass die Leute mit diesen neuen
Problemen und der Weltlage nicht
nachkommen wenn du jetzt erfolgreiche
Klima Umwelt Nachhaltigkeitspolitik
machen willst wie willst du das denn
schaffen alle Leute mitzunehmen das ist
der Punkt also mich nervt natürlich im
Augenblick wie die AFD und übrigens auch
die
wagenknechtpartei ja damit punktet und
zu sagen wir machen den klimablödsinn
nicht mit also gerade bei der
wagenknechtpartei fasse ich mich an den
Kopf ja weil es gibt andere Dinge wo man
sagt okay da wurde gründlich drüber
nachgedacht aber über bei dem Punkt
billig Populismus ja einfach zu sagen
die Leute können die Grünen nicht leiden
wegen hier und das hat sich verteuert
und da sind Auflagen und ich kann nicht
mehr bauen und so weiter und dass ich
diese dieser dieser ganze Zorn da entlät
ich meine an der Notwendigkeit eine
entsprechende Nachhaltigkeitspolitik zu
machen und zwar die eigentlich noch viel
schneller zu machen als wir sie jetzt
machen führt ja kein Weg dran vorbei
jetzt würdest du wahrscheinlich sagen
schlechtes Handwerk oder schlecht
kommuniziert ich frage mich immer wie
kommuniziert man das dening gut also ich
ich finde schon ich we ich weiß nicht
wie du das siehst das könnte ich dir ja
sehr lange begründen ich finde du kannst
es auf jeden Fall nicht so machen du
kannst do nicht hingehen und sagen pass
auf machen wir um es dann doch nicht zu
machen machen wir ein bisschen machen
wir vielleicht machen wir gar nicht das
war bei der gasumlage so das war bei der
spritpreisbremse so das ist jetzt wieder
so bei den bei den bauernprotesten
erinner dich mal daran die Ansage kam
fast über Nacht und es war noch kein
Trecker aus dem aus der Scheune gefahren
da war die ganze Ansage quasi Schoner
terten also das schlecht kommuniziert
schlechtes
handwer das dieses wermepumpen da
heizungsgesetz D das genauso dass das
von vorne bis hinten murst und verkorst
war ja es diente einem guten Zweck aber
es war falsch so wie es gemacht wurde ja
belastet es die falschen und so weiter
das räum mich alles ein meine Frage ist
weil wir jetzt nicht AFD spielen wollen
und wissen wie wir dagegen sind ja wie
hätte man es denn machen müssen und
darüber wird so wenig geredet es wird
immer darüber geredet was die Regierung
alles falsch macht und man findet in der
Tat ganz viel was sie falsch macht auch
gerade in der Klimapolitik aber wir
reden viel zu wenig darüber wie die
Klimapolitik aussehen könnte ja gibt dir
ein ganz anderes Beispiel
dieser Tage kaum beachtet
traut sich
ein Politiker an eine absolut heilige
Kuh dieses deutschen Systems dran und
ich ich sag nicht welches System erstmal
weil ich noch nicht klar machen will um
wen es sich handelt der sagt nee das
bezahlen wir nicht mehr warum nicht ja
es gibt einfach keine wissenschaftliche
Evidenz kon du redest ja homöopathtie so
kein Gesundheitsminister vorm hat sich
das in all den Jahrzehnten vorher
getraut weil er weiß wie wichtig in
deutschen ihre globuli sind Karl
Lauterbach ist wahrscheinlich der
einzige Minister der keine Angst davor
hat sich Feinde zu machen würde gerne
noch mal zurück ich habe
dieser Tage was interessant gelesen äh
da schrieb jemand ich glaube es war
Virginia Kirst die die Korrespondentin
der der Welt in
Rom die sagte die wahre Wiege der
bauernproteste liegt in Italien und die
wahre wiege auch überhaupt dieses ganzen
dieser ganzen populistischen Bewegung
und weil es Italien war es mich
natürlich besonders interessiert sie
sagt trumpisten in Amerika gelbwesten in
Frankreich die Bauern in Deutschland
vieles von dieser Wut sozusagen von
denen da unten gegen die da ob
hat sich in Italien schon deutlich
früher artikuliert und sie sie
beschreibt das Jahr 2008 der 8 November
2008 damals haben sich ich erinnere mich
auch noch daran in in Städten im ganzen
Land haben sich die Leute versammelt zum
zum vtag zum vday zum wafanulo day ja
das heißt also freiübersetzt sozusagen
zum verpisst euch Tag eigentlich heißt
es leckt mich am arschtag ja das Ziel
war sozusagen Politikern einen richtigen
Denkzettel verpassen zu verpassen weil
sie die Schnauze voll davon hatten dass
da ständig Leute ins Amt kommen die vor
der Wahl wer weiß was versprechen und
hinterher sich nur noch um ihren eigenen
Vorteil kümmern aber das W der
Geschichte nie anders gewesen ne ist ja
kein neues Phänomen nein aber in der
jüngeren Zeit würde ich sagen schon weil
wenn du dir mal anschaust was daraus
erwachsen ist ein Jahr später hat Beppe
Grillo dann damals der Komiker hat dann
seine seine cinquistelle die die fünf
Sterne Partei gegründet so eine
populistische antipartei die und da sind
wir bei dem rontiment praktisch kein
Programm hatte außer gegen die da oben
zu sein und das hat ausgereicht 2013
haben Sie dann auf anhb 26% geholt und 5
Jahre später haben sie dann die Wahl
gewonnen das war war sehr interessant
die haben haben dann hinterher die Wahl
wieder verloren weil sie ist faktisch
die sind mit jedem in die Kiste gegangen
und man hat ihen ihre ihr Engagement
nicht mehr abgenommen aber es war Inter
im Rückblick war das der Vorbote für den
brexit für Trump für den Aufstand der
gelbwesten die die die Bauern in den
Niederlanden z.B jetzt für die
traktorkolonnen hier in Deutschland es
ist immer dieser Kulturkampf wir da
unten gegen die da oben die abgehängten
vielleicht sollte man zu Italien noch
dazu sagen dass vorher noch noch die
großartige erra Berlusconi und so weiter
war ja die natürlich einen unglaublichen
Verdruss durch viele
Bevölkerungsschichten gegenüber der rich
kommenden Elite ja und diesem diesem
Kartell aus aus Medienmacht
Wirtschaftsmacht und politischer Macht
und so weiter entfesselt hat ne was was
das überhaupt erstmal befeuert hat
dieses ganz grundsätzliche Misstrauen
aber ich glaube tatsächlich Markus dass
der entscheidende Punkt den du damit
angesprochen hast dass das Vertrauen in
die Politik oder in Politiker im
Allgemeinen ist heute auf einem für die
Bundesrepublik historischen Tiefstand
und meine Befürchtung ist dass es noch
sehr viel tiefer sinken kann und ich
sage ja immer gerne liberale Demokratien
sind zwingend auf Vertrauen angewiesen
Diktaturen sind es nicht ne die sind auf
Angst angewiesen W Leute nur genug Angst
vor dem Staat haben dann parieren sie
schon liberale Demokratien sind darauf
angewiesen dass die Leute die Parteien
Vertrauen Politikern Vertrauen und so
weiter sonst kann ja eine Demokratie gar
nicht ich weiß ja nicht mehr was ich
wählen soll wenn ich keinem mehr
vertraue Vertrauen in Institutionen habe
Vertrauen in die Polizei habe und so
weiter das ist die absolute Grundlage
dafür dass dass eine liberale Demokratie
tatsächlich funktioniert und nicht
irgendwie nur eine papdemokratie oder
irgend so ein anderer Quatsch ist so und
dieser Vertrauensverlust der geht damit
einher dass die Leute heute die
Möglichkeit haben sich auf ganz andere
Art und Weise zu informieren und zu
desinformieren und er geht auf das von
mir vorhin beschriebene Problem zurück
dass man das Vertrauen darin verloren
hat dass die Politiker die gigantischen
Probleme und Herausforderung in diesem
Land noch lösen oder angehen können mhm
und das ist die ganz ganz schwierige
Situation in der sich ja nicht nur
Deutschland befindet sondern die du
genauso in vielen anderen in
verschiedenen Schattierungen liberalen
Demokratien findest und deswegen kann
man schon sagen wir wir wir gehen in
eine Zeit der Krise der liberalen
Demokratie rein und erinner dich mal
dass ich als ich von krastev erzählt
habe von dieser Studie gesprochen habe
dass sie geguckt haben krastev zusammen
und Timothy Garten Ash und so weiter mal
geguckt haben wie sehen die Menschen in
anderen Teilen der Welt auf die Welt und
das Ergebnis war dass die meisten
Menschen in der Welt sehr gerne in einer
westlichen wohlstandsdemokratie leben
möchten und das hier viel schöner finden
als in ihren Heimatländern dass sie aber
gleichzeitig glauben dass die liberalen
Demokratien keine Zukunft mehr haben mhm
also dieses damoklchwert ich möchte
nicht unken ich möchte nicht sagen die
haben keine Zukunft ja also du kennst
mich Zuversicht Optimismus und
Engagement mm aber die Gefahr ist sehr
sehr groß und wenn die Leute das
Vertrauen verlieren daran dass die
liberale Demokratie die beste Staatsform
ist und dann Leute wählen ja mit den
Mitteln der liberalen Demokratie die die
liberale Demokratie eigentlich
abschaffen
wollen es ist eine irrsinnig gefährliche
Entwicklung die wir sehr ernst nehmen
müssen wir müssen viel genauer uns
unsere eigene DNA anschauen und gucken
wie wir das ganze weiterentwickeln und
zwar wirklich mit mit mit großen
Veränderungen die dieses Land ja
tatsächlich braucht in der Hoffnung dass
es viel besser ist wenn wir hier gute
konstruktive Antworten für die Zukunft
geben als wenn wir uns in ständigen
Auseinandersetzung mit denjenigen
aufreiben die unehin keine Lösungen
haben genau also gutes Schlusswort
Richard dank dir sehr ich danke dir auch
das war ein bisschen nachdenklich aber
aber sehr interessanter Austausch wir
hören uns nächste Woche vielen
Dank also schöne Woche dir tschüss
Ciao eine Produktion von mh2 und
podstars bei OMR im Auftrag des
[Musik]
ZDF